so how do you overcome discouragement
that's the question when I dive into
today open a table talk where each week
on pack ideas and insights from
Christian theology and spirituality that
help you become more thoughtful calm and
just a wonderful human being
my name's bretzel furred pastor at the
table in sexy Texas and I'm really
excited to get into this topic today
since honestly to be human is to
encounter discouragement so we've all
been there right your your hum along
things are falling into place they're
going your way when suddenly boom it
hits you discouragement
obstacle after obstacle maybe it's a
conversation with your spouse or a boss
or a child perhaps it's just negative
feedback you receive perhaps it's simply
evidence that you get that like you're
failing or at least not doing as well as
you hoped or thought you would and then
it hits you that deep sense of
discouragement which if prolonged can
eventually turn into despair the great
Christian spiritual writer Thomas Merton
he speaks to this and what's going on in
the soul when he wrote these words in
the book new seeds of contemplation he
said in every man there is hidden some
root of despair because in every man
there is a pride that vegetate s' in the
springs weeds and rank flowers of
self-pity as soon as our resources fail
us but the man who is truly humble
cannot despair because in the humble man
there is no longer any such thing as
self-pity
what I think is so brilliant about
mertens quote and do forgive his very
male-centric language he was writing a
long time ago but what's the genius
about his insight is is that
discouragement is actually a
manifestation of self-pity of this sense
of oh poor me my life so terrible which
itself has roots of a certain pride
right we're shocked when we fail we're
undone when we struggle and then we find
ourselves discouraged so what's the
antidote well I think it's hiding right
there in Mertens quote he says the
antidote to discouragement is humility a
humility that says of course I can't do
it like on my own in my own strength of
course I'll have to pray and rely on God
and find his strength in a sense of his
spirit of course I'll need feedback in
help from others of course this will be
a hard road because right we're just a
man over just a woman we're not gods and
as human beings we should not be quite
so shocked at our setbacks I should not
be dismayed at my imperfections instead
humbly accept them and even after a
while we might even go beyond that and
begin to thank God for them because
honestly it's making us better we're
learning we're growing we're becoming
better and then what's the next step we
move forward we don't wallow in
self-pity we don't try to draw others
into our drama and have them feel real
bad for us instead we simply name what
we're feeling and then we embrace
humility and then we move forward
trusting that as first Peter 5:5 says
God resists the proud but he gives grace
to the humble
well that's all for today if you enjoyed
this video please like it comment share
it with a friend
and to ensure you don't miss future
episodes go ahead and subscribe to my
youtube channel by searching bretzel
furred grace and peace